just a weekend especially a pay weekend
you know you can kind of cut up a little
bit and then you go up in there on
Monday and it's like what the hell just
happened I think I waste a lot of money
on luxury grocery items I don't need to
spend $7 I'm tiny hunk of cheese about
$400 because I hate I'm gonna go hunt it
over here and guess that my spending
vice is alcohol and going out I'm gonna
estimate like one to two hundred per
weekend I guess I don't like that would
be a thousand that's like with forever
oh my god the producers face is
terrified right now this is a ballpark
estimate but I am sure that I spent too
much on Amazon I'll be like oh my god it
would be so great if I had a yoga mat at
home and I'll buy yoga mat don't lose it
so I don't think I'm going to be
surprised but it's probably gonna hit me
in the gate like a great chick seamless
demo taco 14:24 and I probably could
multiply that by a thousand times
because that's how much tamil taco I eat
another damo taco taco taco taco
purchase Papa John's
it doesn't even it doesn't even have
what I ate but clearly it must have been
tasty as he'll to be 2872
it makes me feel like everything that my
dad tells me as far as son you need to
budget you need to think about what
you're buying you don't need to spend
$20.00 when you go eat out it is ringing
in my hair right now and it's making me
say Trey you have got to get your [ __ ]
together one discovery so far I go to
the grocery store twice a day on average
I spent 21 dollars and seventy seven
cents at the grocery store oh [ __ ] oh
that hurts
okay Amazon 22 bucks $100 at cb2 another
$22 on Amazon
[Music]
hmm did I really need to buy sheets from
West aisle I wish I could return what
I've already slept in them and they feel
great alright so first up we have on the
latest statement Macri Park for $15 yep
that's a bar that's checks out 23 60
that is a restaurant in Brooklyn where I
go to get margaritas so yep about checks
as well oh my god you said one mine but
that's so many dumb expenses oh my god I
should just convince drunk me to take
the subway instead of hopping into a cab
and that would save me so much money it
is very easy and quick to spend money
and it's nothing but a tap a tap of that
Dom Oh taco the food is there in 30
minutes but five taps of that Dom Oh
taco and you have guy you know you were
out of maybe $100 feel like I thought
that I was saving money because I
haven't bought anything big and
everything I've been buying is in like
12 to 15 dollar increments but now that
I'm looking at it those have really
added up in general I mean I'm just
trying to be tighter about my money
always and try to think through smarter
ways to track my spending and how I
enable myself to spend on stuff I think
this is very illuminating for that if
you are privileged enough and lucky
enough to be able to treat yourself and
take care of yourself and pay attention
to the things that make you happy then I
say go for it